When you're a kid
You think the universe revolves around you
You think that you'll always be
protected and cared for
Then
one day
you realize that's not true
Because when you're alone as a kid
the monsters see you as weaker
you don't even know they're getting closer
Nooo!!!
Until it's too late
Here
take it
My grandfather thinks this town is cursed
That all the bad things that happen in this town
are because of one thing
An evil thing
Bill, if you will come with me
you'll float, too.
Georgie?
I saw something
A clown
Yeah, I saw him too
You'll float too
What happens
when another Georgie goes missing?
Or one of us?
You'll float too
Are you just gonna pretend it isn't happening
like everyone else in this town?
You'll float too!
If we stick together
We win
You'll float too!
[doll laughs]